la plupart de mes collègues n'ont jamais
mis les pieds dans une entreprise il
ancien l'entreprise des organisations du
marketing études de marché et c'est
inquiétant
et pour aller plus loin de
l'entrepreneuriat comment créer son
entreprise et il enseigne aux étudiants
l'audace d'entreprendre comme enseigner
l'audace d'entreprendre à des étudiants
lorsqu'on n'a jamais créé d'entreprise
lorsqu'on n'a jamais mis les pieds dans
une entreprise
et lorsqu'on sait pas comment ça marche
et une entreprise
moi je dis que lorsqu'on veut mettre en
place ce genre de process d'expérience
entreprenariale vont être passés par à
mon avis les différentes étapes de la
création d'entreprise de la réflexion
jusqu'à la mise en place et même pour
aller plus loin des fois échoué parce
que l'échec aussi c'est intéressant y a
qu'en france où on pense que ben a
finalement échoué c'est quelque chose de
catastrophique
wallah aux états unis par exemple on
pense que échoué c'est de
l'apprentissage
alors je vais vous parler de quelque
chose d'un peu nom usuel ans et je vais
sortir du cadre habituel est par contre
moi je parlerais plutôt de thinking out
of the box
c'est ce que j'enseigne aux étudiants
aux jeunes aux différentes personnes que
je rencontre et c'est pour ça que je
parle de différents contextes
on crée pas de la même manière en france
aux états unis en tunisie en afrique du
sud en asie et ses problématiques
culturelles problématique aussi de
process problématiques juridiques
fiscales financières de levée de fonds
les business angels ne sont pas les
mêmes et capital risqueur ne sont pas
les mêmes les structures publiques
d'appui et d'accompagnement et dead à la
création ne sont pas les mêmes et c'est
pour ça qu'on va essayer de voir comment
va finalement trouver la meilleure
manière est le meilleur contexte pour
créer son entreprise et développer son
idée est derrière aller vers plus qu'on
appelle une vraie opportunité d'affaires
généralement un projet de ce genre il
est porté par une personne vous avez une
personne qui vient vous voir ça c'est
marrant parce que assez souvent vous
avez des étudiants qui viennent le voir
dans le bureau n 10 18 19 ans monsieur
j'ai l'idée du siècle
ok tu peux développer
oui au fait je vais créer ça à ses
assassins t'as ton ordinateur
bah tape le nom de cette entreprise en
fait il se rend compte finalement qu'il
ya au moins 300 concurrents
ok généralement ils font la tête mais
pour les plus courageux ils reviennent à
la charge
ils reviennent ils reviennent et y en a
pas mal qui crée derrière leur
entreprise même à 18 ans et là dessus je
vais vous parler d'un étudiant que j'ai
eu en deuxième année et à 3 ans qui
s'appelle bogdan qui m'a marqué bogdan
il est d'origine roumaine et c'est un
geek
au fait j'ai pas si vous savez ce que
c'est qu'un geek un geek bas c'est
quelqu'un qui est féru d'informatique
etc
et je vous avouerai quand il m'a parlé
de son projet j'ai absolument rien
compris
tout ce que j'ai retenu c'est que tout
simplement ça parle de téléchargement de
musique et j'ai senti un peu le côté un
peu informel illégal limites
vous savez que les entrepreneurs
illégaux il y en a un paquet et c'est ce
qu'il réussisse le plus bien sûr
amplifie d'impôt du tout et donc il me
parlait de ce process j'ai eu du mal à
comprendre donc j'ai appelé un collègue
à moi qui étais plutôt très bon
l'informatique on a discuté ensemble et
il s'avère au fait à l'avant de la
discussion qu'il avait un super projet
est derrière au fait les semaines qui
ont suivi d'un filet au final j'ai eu en
cours et si c'était quelqu'un qui te
remets tout le temps un cours pourquoi
c'est simple parce qu'en fait il
développé son idée c'est dans son idée a
été développé plutôt au niveau d
amérique du nord et donc il avait
toujours un décalage
donc il travaillait le soin et d'un
ménage on y est on en a parlé petit à
petit et au fait il ya développé son
projet etc
est arrivé le mois de mai il semble et
les étudiants doivent partir en stage ce
qui fait il emmène deux de ses collègues
18 ans il leur payer 3000 dollars tout
compris nos jets nourris et blanchis et
c'est en stage à new york
son premier client alors j'ai du mal
avec cette personne s'émeuve a dit
peuvent-ils dit à chaque fois de nom
donc c'est son premier client neuf mois
plus tard il développe son entreprise il
ouvre en roumanie
pour des problématiques bien sûr de
fiscalité sont peu pava hec fait un
billet entrepreneuriat pour avoir le
côté un peu plus je dirais cadre et son
deuxième client ça a été timbaland
c'est le plus gros producteur aux états
unis n'aura pu s et que c'était un
accident
première année exercice
il semble si je raconte pas de conneries
c'est je crois à 600000 euros d'achat de
chiffre d'affaires pour 4000 euros de
charges
faites vos calculs donc il ya des
expériences comme ça qui vous marque
mais je peux vous dire qu'il ya beaucoup
d'échecs aussi en entrepreneuriat parce
que c'est quelque chose un peu tabou en
france on a toujours envie de
d'encourager d'aller vers cette voie d'
qui est la création de son sa propre
entreprise son propre emploi et c'est
vrai que c'est très tentant pour les
femmes pour les jeunes pour les seniors
pour les sans emploi pour les immigrés
qui souhaitent s'intégrer dans la
société parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
trouver un emploi pour les personnes
porteuses d'un handicap parce qu'elles
ont besoin de s'autodéterminer
et aussi parce que tout simplement
l'entrepreneuriat c'est une expérience à
part unique
on vit beaucoup de choses dans
l'entrepreneuriat on vit bas la
difficulté tout simplement de finir les
fins de mois on gagne pas beaucoup
d'argent contrairement à ce qu'on peut
vous dire on est hyper stressée anxieux
d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup de recherches
qui sont faits en ce sens notamment du
côté de montpellier avec olivier torres
est généralement la plupart des
entrepreneurs n'ont pas de vie sociale
soit il sépare en cours soit ils seront
lâchés en cours parce que tout
simplement ils ont des oreilles un de
plus que deux présidents avant lui
je crois que mon avis ils travaillent
plus que notre président est donc c'est
un état d'esprit avant tout c'est un
état d'esprit qu'il faut avoir
généralement on vous dit attention
l'entrepreneuriat soit on est
entrepreneur soit on ne l'est pas c'est
complètement faux on peut apprendre à
entreprendre les circonstances peuvent
vous amener à entreprendre
c'est pour ça qu'on parle de différentes
catégories d'entrepreneurs et les
entrepreneurs qui sont plus d'en bas j'y
vais parce que j'en ai envie
il y en a d'autres qui sont plutôt
entrepreneurs par nécessité je prends le
cas par exemple de stack de quelqu'un
seniors j'ai pas si vous avez un désolé
de dire ça mais en france on est senior
à partir de 45 ans et eux lorsque vous
êtes seniors à 50 ans et que vous êtes
hyper qualifiés tout ce que vous voulez
et du jour au lendemain en fait on vous
demande de quitter l'entreprise essayer
de chercher un job vous allez voir c'est
hyper compliqué pourquoi parce que la
tendance actuelle elle est simple on va
essayer de recruter des jeunes qui coûte
4 5
dd fois dix fois moins cher que le
saignant et qui peuvent éventuellement
amener ben finalement en travaillant 3 4
5 bat plus de valeur ajoutée que le
saignant donc du coup on licencie de ces
liens en seniors se retrouve un peu dans
la mise parce que trouver un job à cet
âge là c'est un peu compliqué donc la
seule alternative pour maintenir un
certain rythme de vie est aussi garder
un peu une part de son ego c'est aussi
de créer son propre emploi et donc il ya
beaucoup de seniors qui se lance dans
l'entreprise en tout cas dans
l'expérience de la création d'entreprise
et ils ne sont pas un cas unique
de plus en plus de jeunes maintenant
pense à la création d'entreprise parce
que quand vous regardez les taux de
chômage à la sortie des business school
ou université ou tout ce que vous voulez
on a de plus en plus de mal à trouver un
emploi
du moins des sens et du coup derrière
les personnes bas creuse au fond d'eux
mêmes de leurs motivations de leur hobby
de ce qui les intéresse dans leur
entourage pour trouver des idées qui
pourrait éventuellement les intéressés
derrière développer des business et
c'est ce qu'on voit de plus en plus bien
sûr en france même si on est très en
retard bien sûr par rapport aux autres
pays
j'aime l'entrepreneuriat oui j'ai pas
peur de le dire
j'aime et love new york paris singapour
peut aussi dire iluv l'entrepreneurship
pourquoi parce que l'entrepreneuriat ça
vous permet de réfléchir
il ya deux logiques en fait en
entreprenant il ya une logique d'action
une logique de réflexion vous pouvez
passer toute votre vie à réfléchir et
jamais vous allez passer le cap et aller
vers la création d'entreprise
parce que vous dites que ça engage
beaucoup de choses parce que vous dites
que finalement je peux perdre mes
économies
ma femme peux me lâcher si je perds mes
économies parce qu'elle pourra plus
faire de shopping derrière et donc je
fais un peu de provoc je revends dit là
dessus pour faire plaisir aux dames
je sais pas si vous le savez mais les
femmes entreprennent beaucoup plus que
les hommes et les femmes sont beaucoup
plus courageuse entreprenariale mans
parlant que les ans je vous cite
l'exemple d'une femme qui m'a vraiment
je dirais interpellé sur la façon de
réfléchir c'est une femme qui venait
d'avoir des jumeaux je crois elle est
partie dans un bar on a discuté je crois
trois ans après son expérience entre
dans un bar avec sa poussette double
poussette elle voulait prendre un truc à
boire et ce qui se passe c'est que
finalement il faut que j'aille très très
vite
c'est que cette dame là on la regardait
de travers parce que ses enfants pleurer
et s'est étalé avec ses couches etc
elle a une idée c'est simple créer un
bar pour maman et elle a créé son bar
pour maman c'est un bar où vous arrivez
ce que des mamans avec leur poussette
c'est un bordel monstrueux mais c'est un
bordel agréable et elle a réussi à
pérenniser cette expérience vous voyez
en fait ya beaucoup d'opportunités qu'on
développe au travers tout simplement du
hasard
ac essaye de vous dire ça c'est mon fan
au plus tôt c'est moi c'est la personne
que j'admire le plus après omer bien sûr
la personne la plus gentille au monde
pour moi c'est l'image de l'entrepreneur
vous pouvez effectivement avoir du mal à
penser cela et tous les entrepreneurs
doivent être opportuniste tous les
entrepreneurs doivent penser argent
parce que il faut arrêter de penser
qu'un business model dans une entreprise
ça peut être perrin si vous ne gagnez
pas de l'argent et que vous pouvez pas
tout simplement faire du caritatif
pouvait faire du caritatives mais il
faut que votre business model tienne la
route
il faut que ça soit derrière rentable
financièrement parlant et je vais aller
plus loin pour vous choqué c'est que
sans argent
vous ne pouvez pas créer d'entreprise
l'argent est le moteur de l'économie et
le moteur de l'entrepreneuriat c'est
pour ça qu'il ya des jeunes qui ont des
super idée sont obligés de brader une
partie de leur capital parce que tout
simplement ils n'ont pas d'argent on
pouvoir aller chercher des business
angels des capital risqueurs
même si les capital risqueurs je voulais
des conseils d'une façon catégorique
mais en tout cas ils ont besoin d'argent
et avec l'argent on peut faire
fonctionner les choses je peux avoir la
plus belle idée au monde et jamais je ne
pourrai la développer parce que tout
simplement je n'ai pas l'argent qui va
avec
et bien sûr il ya d'autres variables
comme la motivation etc
le réseau et j'en passe
lorsqu'on parle d'entrepreneuriat
généralement on regarde y ont réfléchi à
ça parce que finalement l'expérience de
l'entrepreneuriat c'est un labyrinthe
il ya plein de problèmes dans merde et
on a des problèmes d'argent et des
problèmes de personnel on a des
problèmes de compétences on a des
problèmes de locaux on a des problèmes
de développement technologique on a
développé des problèmes pour déposer des
preuves et parce qu'on a pas assez
d'argent pour déposer le brevet et c'est
un accident
donc ça s'enchaîne et généralement ben
finalement pour moi ce qui est au centre
spa c'est l'homme avec un grand h
hommes femmes jeunes tout ce que vous
voulez et ces personnes là sont capables
d'atteindre le nirvana qui est celui de
la création d'entreprise en passant par
du marketing du juridique de la
stratégie et du business models inc
le coeur d'un d'une entreprise et c'est
ce qu'on voit de plus en plus maintenant
aux états unis il ya des émissions sais
pas si vous allez regarder du côté de
youtube
tu avais mission pitch élévateur pitch
aux états unis vous pouvez gagner et
lever des fonds en direct dans un talk
show un peu à l'américaine en télé
réalité et ça se passe sur quoi c'est
sur un pitch de trente mille 30 secondes
une minute et surtout sur votre business
model quand on rencontre des veilles
défendent et ses eaux des fonds
d'investissement ils vous disent ok on
lit le dossier qui fait 300 pages très
rapidement mais ce qui va les intéresser
c'est un la personne et de le business
model est ce qu'il est rentable
est ce qu'il va me permettre de gagner
de l'argent pas c'est ça le plus
important est le business modèle pour
moi
on peut avoir des business models assez
je dirais commun comme le freemium et
que c'était un accident
mais pour moi le business model c'est
comme l'adn humaine il est unique et
cela s'explique par le fait que ben
pourquoi aucune personne n'a été capable
de dupliquer le business model par
exemple de yahoo de facebook etc
alors qu'il est connu tout le monde
connaît le business model parce que tout
simplement les ressources les acteurs
les clients l'offre et ses accès
baal est unique et c'est ce qui fait la
différence c'est ce qui lui permet
d'avoir ce fameux avantage concurrentiel
et voilà un peu le cheminement jeu
reprend une idée de tirer verstraete sur
l'entrepreneuriat on parle d'une idée
qu'on va tester qui va se développer en
business heures plus tôt opportunités
d'affaires un business model qui va avec
une vision stratégique et le fameux
business plan en france on adore le
business plan vous allez voir le
banquier qui n'a jamais vu de business
plan elle vous dira il est où votre
business plan
en fait c'est ça la preuve le problème
c'est que aux états unis maintenant on a
une réflexion qui est différente on part
de l'idée on teste c'est que c'est un
art et s'était ensuite on monte notre
business plan pour aller voir les
financiers en france non avant de monter
son entreprise on montre son business
plan etc et on va voir les investisseurs
les banquiers tout ce que vous
c'est dommage parce que finalement tout
ça ça tue un peu je reviens un peu ce
que disait mon collègue la créativité
l'innovation vous la tuer directement à
la racine et c'est pour ça que peut-être
pas faut faire comme a fait le gamin qui
était dans un bain avec un village
vacances et qui s'est rendu compte qu'il
y avait pas de pain au chocolat et de
croissants et de pain dans tout le
village et qu'il fallait descendre
jusqu'en bas pour chercher son pain est
remonté
elle a pris son vélo un panier il a
rempli des pains au chocolat
décroissants qui l'a négocié exe des
livraisons et c'est comme ça qu'il avait
fait son argent de poche tous les jours
durant les vacances et ainsi de suite
les exemples de femmes et d'hommes qui
ont réussi et en terme business et qui
pour moi
chacun a une expérience à part donc
anita elle est plutôt créatrice des body
shop cofondatrice de zara simoncini
j'ai pas eu connaissez mythique pour
ceux qui sont célibataires rolling
stones donc là on est plutôt sur deviner
ou pas steve jobs ce une des plus grands
entrepreneurs enfin en france tout le
monde là ne lui donne pas le statut
qu'elle devrait avoir pour moi c'est
quelqu'un qui gagne plus d'argent
peut-être que que simoncini parce que
travers des contrats qu'elle a mis en
place bétonner bien comme il faut avec
le fameux miss france et d'autres
activités que la plupart d'entre nous
nous connaissons connais pas coco chanel
et ses excédents et
on va néanmoins je crois une heure pour
dire tous amis donc très rapidement
lorsque vous mettez en place un projet
entrepreneurial
c'est vraiment se baser sur votre
famille la love manie le soutient la
formation avec tout ce qui se met en
place en incubateur écoles la structure
d'accompagnement
c'est tout ce qui est expérience des
fois c'est bien d'avoir l'expérience
avant de se lancer parce que ça nous
permet de connaître le milieu le
savoir-faire les connaissances etc etc
et bien sûr la société le hasard comme
je vous disais la dame avec sa poussette
c'est vraiment le hasard qui l'a poussé
à aller vers la création d'entreprise et
pour finir sachez que l'entrepreneuriat
est fait pour tout le monde
tout le monde est capable d'entreprendre
il suffit juste d'avoir de la motivation
est une très bonne idée
ensuite que vous soyez blanc noir orange
et vert handicapé immigrés seniors
jeunes femmes hommes jeunes peu importe
mon avis c'est une expérience pour tout
le monde
merci beaucoup